he was funny and he was fast and he
would weave
in and out of characters he would get
shakespearean he would just you know get
into like oh yes thank you
yes tell us the guys sitting at home
going what the hell going on there yes
there's the kid going that's not the way
yes then he's like martha graham i think
matt and ball and chain and kick and
bologna yes thank you
uh
it's it's not that common that comedians
take their own lives i mean it does
happen
with rob and robin was a big one for a
lot of people because he was
he was not just a comedian he was like a
cultural icon in terms of like his films
you think all the different movies like
i was in and
he had such a range too that's what you
like to me when you know how brilliant a
person really is like
do you remember that film that he did
about the uh crazy uh
film processing guy it was like 24 hour
film
remember those little film booths photo
booths that people would go to
back in the old days you youngsters we
would have a camera
and the camera would have film in it and
you'd have to bring the film to a place
for processing and robin williams did a
film about a guy who was a psychopath
who was obsessed with someone
from processing their picture one hour
photo that's what it was nice
it was [ __ ] great and you just
from that film you realize the range
this man had right
right you know i mean from goodwill
hunting from
you know so many different yeah he was
he's a genius
then was on our show this show and the
old show
a total of nearly 50 times right 50
times 50 times
two things would happen because robin
was on the program one
i didn't have to do anything yes
i all i had to do was sit here and watch
the machine
yeah uh and two uh he
people would watch if they knew robin
was on the show the
the viewership would go up because they
wanted to see robin yeah
and and believe me that wasn't just true
of television
i believe that was true of the kind of
guy he was people
were drawn to him because of this
electricity
this this whatever it was that he
radiated that that propelled him and
empowered him
uh and then he came on when i came back
after my heart surgery
robin was nice enough to to come on that
night and it was very very funny and
very very
uh uh appropriate and here's a picture
that i will now
uh cherish even more than i had
previously
there are four people right there wow
two of which two of which wildly funny
insanely funny uh two are not
last night i went down to the comedy
store and um
they had actually had a uh a memorial
service for robin williams
and uh it was awesome man it was
you know just like
so many people from back in the day came
out
that were down there i actually i'm
wondering when all the last time all of
that group of people were down there um
and they were all telling stories it was
like i got there late unfortunately
but uh norm macdonald yakov schmiernoff
had some great stories
uh jackson purdue
then uh there's a couple people that
were part of his improv group
we're all telling all these great
stories and uh it was a really great
thing but i gotta tell you man that was
you know there's one of those things
where you really you think you know yeah
i love that guy i love his movies i i
think that guy's hilarious
you know you don't realize it and then
something like that happens just like
wow man i had no idea how much that guy
uh affected me i did get a chance
um one time to do a show with him
uh he always um you know he would just
come down to clubs i'd always heard
about i know he did it he lived up in
san francisco but people were saying
like yeah this is open mic he went to
every single week
um bartnik told this great story about
uh
how he was at a concert he was kind of
like the
like the unofficial mayor of like san
francisco when
they needed like a laugh or something
like i guess bartnik was at some
big concert and uh it was an outdoor
thing and it rained
and um you know so like apologize
everybody the bands can't go on
everybody's standing
[ __ ] looking like a bunch of [ __ ]
wet
sheltered dogs and stuff and robin
williams was in the crowd
and he just went up on stage
and like a [ __ ] rain poncho and did
45 minutes
in front of an uh a soaking wet angry
crowd that wasn't getting their show
and he crushed just did like a
headlining set
and uh and then in the end like the sun
was coming out and he's like all right
the bands are coming out
blah blah just went right back into the
crowd just he was like a zillion
stories like that that i heard and um so
anyways i was
doing uh jeff garland had this show
he does uh every now and again down at
the ucb
and uh it's this really cool format in
the end he has like this improv game
called uh
the combo platter and it's basically
they pick a
subject and each person has to go up and
riff on it for five minutes
and then you sit down and then the next
round is you go back
up again but anybody can interrupt
anybody at any time
and it just starts going you just start
adding to whatever they're doing and
when you know one night i went down
there and i was doing the show with them
and robin
showed up and garland knew him and
everything and they went in with the
show and i actually got to do improv
standing right next to him doing improv
i literally felt like i was on comic
relief
you know i mean we're sitting in the
chairs right this is like such a
[ __ ] weird moment but we always
sitting in the chair next to him you
know he had that thick arm hair
it's like we were the space between us
was a little tight
but it wasn't anywhere where we still
should have been touching but his arm
hair was so [ __ ]
thick it actually was it actually was
touching my arm i had to move my arm
i remember thinking all those jokes that
he used to do about how he felt like he
was wearing a sweater and all that type
of thing but
it was one of obviously one of the great
things i ever got to do and
fortunately because he was such an open
guy and such a
nice guy sweet guy he didn't
didn't you know come in with that you
know i've been doing this forever
get out of the way kid he didn't have
that vibe at all he was like a really
vulnerable
kind of vibe that because he came with
that vibe i was actually able to like
enjoy it as it was happening
rather than look back on it
and be like uh yeah i got to do that but
i
i was so in my head i had to like knock
him down you know
that's like something i have to do
sometimes when i get a gig that's so
big i literally have to develop a
certain level of hatred for this
person that i don't hate i have to be
like you know what [ __ ] this guy [ __ ]
this guy for making me feel so [ __ ]
uncomfortable with this
success or whatever but the way robin
was you didn't have to do that when
you're around them so uh
you know thanks to jeff garland for
[ __ ]
you know having that show so i could
have that memory but it's definitely a
huge huge
huge [ __ ] uh indescribable uh
loss and that just sucks i hate that it
ends that way
you know
[Music]